hey everybody welcome to a very special
edition of beginner breakdown I am your
host Eric Hanson I'm a grandmaster from
Canada
current resident GM here and today I
thought it would be nice to look at a
game from the October nights tournament
it was it's kind of slow
somebody selected it game between
Matthew Manley and Scott Anderson so
interesting game that that took place in
that local tournament so without further
ado d4 d5 c4 c6 this is the Slav and it
can it still hasn't been decided which
which type what's going to happen
there's a few different moves here
I mean Knight f3 Knight of 6 e 6 as
possible yeah they can take you know you
can take on c4 but these two players
seem to be familiar with the opening
quite a bit I'm not sure their ratings
actually so Knight f6 Knight c3 and this
this allows D takes c4 which which is
what happened and there's a lot of
theory in this this variation and it's a
very playable line for black and pretty
easy to understand so it's not it's a
it's a good choice for a lot of people
starting out trying to look for
something not too not too heavy on the
understanding from the understanding
perspective I I personally sometimes
play III quite a bit just to avoid avoid
the the big theory but although both are
good so 93 and D takes e4 this is kind
of the last choice pretty much to
transpose to some other mainline like e
63
you know this kind of like leads to open
like the Moran very popular in a few
World Championship match is very solid
kind of yeah the more solid version for
black a lot of very fantastic games by
guys like Alexei share out there and
this one a phenomenon but anyways 93d
takes e4 black black black takes the
pawn while it's on undefended I guess
that's the simple way to put it and then
a for white replies to stop b5 you can
also try you know III as well but b5 and
this is also this is yeah usually white
white just doesn't give black the
opportunity to do that to play b5 but
there's a few different options here but
this is the main line once once you take
here it's the go away for black can
never played b5 now for example if they
go a six you know III b5 doesn't quite
work there's a knight takes b5 with the
rooks rook on three on a so the main
line here Bishop f5 and this is one of
the reasons why I kind of like this for
a lot of beginners you develop you get
to get both bishops out for black so
it's not one of those openings where you
have to solve solve a bad piece right
off the bat here black plays Bishop f5
and yeah it's time to do that because
white has to have to spend the time to
recuperate the pawn on c4 so Bishop f5
is is logical move there instead of as
anything else like musics just you get
you get the chance to help the bishop
but you should take it
so Bishop f5 95 and they're falling
through both guys kind of knew what was
going on 95 III is although the other
main move here and after like six
we should take c4 this is this is you
know another variation within this
opening in the Slav often
often goes at the we should be for
castle castle and white tries to play
for some sort of year for push at the
right time but a totally different
variation sub variation they should have
595 so instead of recapturing with the
bishop on c4 white leaves the option
white likes to take with a knight here
and then take c4 is the threat and maybe
maybe then you won't play e3 he might
look to play something like e for that's
that's the benefit of of this variation
over the other one is you might be able
to go he for one go before right here is
not possible but 95 sometimes prepares F
3 and E 4 so 95 9b d7 and said e 6 as
possible 2 and F 3 here and I take c4
but 9b d7 is the current trend you know
development move the knight doesn't have
really another natural square except for
net a6 which I've seen before but 97 is
the most standard standard Square to
keep your pieces coordinated Knight
takes e4 recapture the pawn a bit
self-explanatory there we capture the
party now we still have that option of
getting that pawn Center that I was
talking about
so Knight b6 still falling theory
yeah I'm trying if there's not some
other moves I know about too much but
Knight b6 is is the Kerr movie why black
wants to get rid of the knight on c4
then n c4 is a pretty good night
it controls quite a few squares
especially because like if this night
wasn't on c4 black might actually be
playing a five and one go and
challenging that center that would be
better than challenging the center with
a move like c6 to c5 because he's
already spent one putting a pawn to c6
if you could go with a father one go
that would be more efficient so Knight
b6 offering a trade this is a very salt
opening so I mean black black plays
first equalizes then goes for the
advantage it's not as that's usually the
order so he sticks with the standard
standard stuff Knight b6 offering a
trade challenge challenge white a bit
it's the other benefit though of course
is we open the D file for the Queen some
pressure on you 395 white White's
keeping the pieces on the board not
making it easy for black especially
because white wants to expand in the
center house and if you want to expand
the center take that space if you have a
lot of space you don't want to let your
opponent rate off too many pieces you
prefer to prefer to keep more pieces on
the board then then with less space for
black in this case it's going to be much
more uncomfortable every piece so you
want to keep the pieces on the board
when you have more space for the most
part because it's a lot more I'm buzzing
for for the other side to play with with
little space to maneuver around so
Knight 9505 ya5 well it's not the it's
not the sharpest opening so black has
time to play if I like the black doesn't
play if I've I think white plays a5
that's one of the one of the ideas
sometimes and it can be really annoying
Oh once again make the type of waiting
move let's say g6e six also be standard
but this type of sequence a5 kicking the
night out and I can go anywhere let's
say the neck goes goes to two ds/dt five
maybe you move like a six is actually
quite quite annoying undermining on
upon v7 and and therefore the part on c6
goes really weak so it's just a bit of
an annoyance that black doesn't have to
worry about and positionally most
importantly a5 does pretty much
permanently give him give him this
before score at least white will never
have a pawn that can challenge that
square so black will always be
relatively safe so he gains he gained
some dark squares he gained some dark
squares for the long term and that's
that's pretty dynamic in that sense both
sides have their Trump's now it's quite
appealing for black to maybe play a six
and stick that Bishop on before because
white can't really challenge that
anymore there's no more a3 so Bishop g5
and when I looked at this game a little
bit beforehand didn't spend too much but
this is one of the most there are a
bunch of moves here there are there is
f3 f3 as it talks about there is there
is III as well there are a few different
moves here it's it's a pretty flexible
position and Bishop g5 is one of them so
it's just it's just the just the one of
the one of the developing moves that
that's possible I mean with a move like
III yeah I mean you're kind of locking
your Bishop and unnecessarily so that's
nuts not really attractive but a move
like f3 f there might be might be pretty
attractive yeah I'm trying to think
maybe g3 is even possible here but like
why does one use that Bishop on c1 so
you know it's nice to develop it and
then play you through so Bishop g5 and
h6 was played a good move for black both
both cars are playing theory though so
they do know their stuff here h6 bishop
h4 Bishop h4 I would have probably done
the same because when I mean if you play
Bishop g5 you do have to almost always
calculate what if they play h6
whenever you're developing your Bishop
kind of close to their king or in enemy
territory you have to you know you have
to be prepared to think about what
happens if they just attack me so he
probably saw this and
you know played Bishop h4 because it's
not normally a big weakness for black to
do that so then when wouldn't really be
a benefit for white to have just given
black this free move and let's say a
game continues so I think I think you
saw this you thought Bishop h4 that's so
that's a good way to about the Bishop e6
6e for active and logical for for the
opening it works just for those just a
double check Bishop takes e4 Knight
takes e4 and that Knight can't take back
because the queen is hanging on d8 so
just just some elementary calculation
there and and it happens in this
structure quite a bit so Bishop it
Bishop h7 not much not much else okay
you never play not Bishop g6 a bit
suicidal they're giving up the bishop
and giving herself some very weak pawns
especially the one on u6 and g6 so
Bishop 87 and maybe even blacks others
too that's one reason why he played you
know age six he knew he had to put his
Bishop back so anyways Bishop e2 I now
know this is when I think the guys are
pretty much out of theory and that's
when mistakes you know or something
happen or I can criticize things a bit
more because before this is the whole
book and both guys seem to know what
they're doing and as I said Magnus
Carlsen did play it so I can't you know
that's that's enough for me
but it's relying on tactics once again
and it takes you for not possible
because of Bishop you know the bishop is
still putting pressure but block now
plays the most natural move doesn't it's
not even - yeah it's I think a lot of us
would it be our first or second choice
white is preparing to Castle black kind
of returns the favor here there should
be seven and now now now black is also
ready to castle and he's also now
actually threatening Knight takes e4
and he renews the same threat without
having to shatter his pawn structure and
now and now this was a pretty critical
point in the game and I was a bit
confused again
this [ __ ] takes f6 that's a no-no I know
don't give a bishop pair don't give the
bishop especially the dark bishop in a
position like this that d4 point
everything is going to be everything is
gonna be weak in a long term it's hard
to fit realize now but that's the case
but that's the case what's the
alternative
why did why do that why did that because
Knight takes e4 I mean now Knight takes
e4 is a threat and there aren't too many
easy ways to defend that Queen d3 is not
a very natural way of defending it but
actually totally playable
I think Queen d3 but not the most
natural I mean you want to move your
queen too much in the opening sometimes
but it would be better
Bishop f3 again why why move a bishop to
the phantom power you can just f3 f3 is
again probably the better better more
logical option here and often there are
these tactics when you have something
like this up Knight takes e4 F takes
just it's a tactic so Bishop xh4 check
and black ones upon but the consequences
in this line specifically this line it
does not work this sort of sequence
because this pattern does happen quite a
bit Bishop e7 Knight c3 they should be
891 and the nighttime b6 is hang but if
it wasn't then this might actually work
but not on b6 and white is up 3 pieces
of 2 but but that night wasn't there
than it would work so I'm not sure if
maybe White was worried that there was
some messy stuff happening I'm not
exactly sure but what he did that's
that's unnecessary
getting up the bishop for no positional
compensation especially in the position
where you have some weak dark squares on
the
formed before not a not a fan of that f3
f3 is is nice for multiple reasons it
really does help shut this down
so anyways Bishop f6 Bishop f6 now a
positions not like lost or much worse
yet but black can probably breathe
pretty comfortably here they're both
going to castle and white doesn't really
have anything besides that nana knight
on e5 might be good it's a bit shaky
it's a bit shaky right now it can be
taken for example and d4 can be
undermined that's that's usually one of
the benefits of having a structure with
you know pont on g6 and c6 that holds
holds white from pushing d5 and then you
bring your rook to that open file like
rook d8 and and that's and it's a it's
easy counter play it's easy counter play
it's not easy for for white to to stop
that stop that initiative against the d4
pawn especially here without that Bishop
protecting it so White Castle no other
real follow up yeah that night that
night can you really move too much you
probably see one thing to notice
probably both sides aren't that happy
with her nights on b6 and c3 then on c3
has no squares to go to can't go here
has to protect you for can't go there so
why it's probably looking to improve
that or I'm looking to improve that when
I'm considering this position and black
same thing doesn't really have any
squares except going backwards but
that's probably what they're gonna end
up doing besides that both sides are
okay Castle castle and now now pretty
much it's like the middle game
especially for I guess a lot of people
they consider the middle game you know
after your castle and this this is it
why I played that for not consistent
with two bishops with two bishops
opening position carries a lot of risk
but I probably agree with this decision
of really strengthening the net on e5
because otherwise
just to make let's say Brooke c1 I have
to watch out for moves like c5 and now I
wish that pawn was on that for
protecting the night because any sort of
any sort of opening up of the position
is gonna favor
you know usually it's gonna favor black
with the bishops especially but that
King on that super strong Bishop on e5
that's uncontested so see if I was an
idea and that it's going to be there
whenever black black is the one who
dictates when when he's gonna play that
so white right f4 I don't you know there
are no other pieces besides the pawn
that can help support that Dirk's for a
knight on e5 so it's really the only
choice I would have liked to play F 3
but not possible
f4 Queen c7 and I'm starting to like
blacks moves he's doing all the he's
doing right moves he's doing right moves
I mean he's not doing anything
he's he's keeping his bishops on good
squares they're not super strong yet but
he's not he's not giving white any any
sort of attack or anything in the
meantime and he's just finishing his
development he's doing he's doing what
he's supposed to do here as I said
usually in this opening his back it's a
solid opening for the most part you
equal equalize and then and then you
start to take over then you men if
things go well then then you take your
chances so now he's developing the Queen
will develop the rooks especially that
weak point on d4 it's better for him to
attack that weak pawn with the rook and
with a queen that Queen can you know do
do multiple things so bringing the rook
in is a games especially because White
has a queen on on d1 is more effective a
more effective way of putting pressure
there
rook f3 and this is just this is just
that's a big no-no that's probably even
worse than giving up the bishop IROC f3
I mean as I usually tell of students and
what
like you have to attack for a reason a
weakness they made or all your pieces
are on one side of the board or
something like that and rook f3 Black
has not made those weakening risky moves
he has actually two bishops near his
King so we count material near the King
you know black is not doing better all
there's no reason to to play rock f3 if
the idea was to play rook g3 and maybe
let's say rook lift like that rook lift
is a bit ambitious to say the least
because to attack he's gonna have to
take risk to open up the position in
that once again will favor favor the two
bishops what's what's a more logical or
natural move in this position for a
white because what black plays Queen c7
he's ready to play most one of the rooks
probably work 88 and put pressure on d4
you don't want your Queen
you don't want your Queen to be on deal
1 when that happens just just to show
for example let's say I play h3 or make
a waiting move rook d8 and now there's
now now we now our queen is tied down to
that pawn and we don't you don't want
your Queen tied down to a pawn you
wanted to be doing a bit more than that
and now c5 is coming and the threat is
much stronger with a rook rook putting
pressure on the Queen compared to
compared to before so I mean there is
there is some urgency here
I don't like White's position but it is
not over at all and he has resources and
he has better moves work f3 may be
attacking maybe you're gonna swing the
rook over the d3 but that really also
helps black here's some potential ideas
on that diagonal so yeah
Queeny one to play which moves our queen
f2 I like that that yeah yeah well tryna
stop c5 is a good I agree with that but
we don't have time to play in the like
rook c1 guys probably work to get Queen
huh it is rook c1 Rick c1 yeah and now
the pawn is saying ah that's what you're
playing okay okay I like that
I like that so you want to you want to
defend it tactically first rook c1 and
95 well so you have the same ideas you
Jews you don't want to get the Queen f2
I guess right you're gonna have to do it
either way because you have that idea or
you have the other option of bringing a
rook to d1 instead of once again getting
like we know - so so both of suggestions
rook c1 Mercury c5 is not a threat
yeah and you don't even need to do Queen
when Queen e1 was fine with a 95 but you
can also throw an 85 after c5 next move
c5 still as impossible because 95 would
be available there is a much probably
much easier way for for blacks to just
attack this if we were to do a rook c1
is it black smooth okay yeah probably
have to remove that Queen e1 now I'd
probably play something like Queen d6
and you end up having to move that rook
to d1 anyways but after it moves like
look d1 Queen before I'm just going to
move all my piece on dark squares
because there are weak dark squares all
over the place there's some serious
there's some serious pressure here
well not work f3 what do we do not work
f3 yeah Queen e1 so Queen e1 and what
was your suggestion young man in the
front Queen b3 I like Queen b3 as
another suggestion as well Queen b3
nothing nothing fancy that's the Queen
out and ok your Queen's not going to see
- same same diagonals that so Queen b3
is what I would have done work f3 The
Rock f3 does not help us and most of
those endeavors we've been looking at
and it also blocks our Bishop and some
lines just just gets in the way to me so
yeah definitely say Queen c7 should be
met by Queen b3 and defend the pawn with
the rook defending the pawn with the
rook so Rick f3 look after yet maybe
even work Adia would have been better
keeping overlook on the Kings side but
there's there's a lot of freedom for
black here he's probably pretty happy
yeah so both works were finite I
probably would prefer to work a 88
because keep it work on the king said
that work on a it's not doing too much
but I think both to keep the advantage
and yeah black is doing everything right
though I I will say that so far I agree
it's most about they're all you know
fundamentally pretty sound he wants to
open up the position but he's not rushed
into the opening up the position because
he knows if black if white tries to take
advantage and try to try to attack
before everything is ready well opening
up attacking usually usually should give
the bishops more space some more
breathing room once any pawn moves or
anything
it'll also increase blacks chances as
well so and now Brooke g3 attacking on
the dark squares is also just visually
not really the right way to go when you
don't have that dark Bishop you don't
have that a battering ram or anything
on the color that you're attacking it's
it's it's just just and black didn't
make any weaknesses unless aged six to
consider weakness but 86 was a weakness
we'd really want a dark for a bishop to
be on maybe see one with some sort of
potential there but we don't have that
Bishop and so h6 is not not a musical
weakness yes there's a small threat here
but it doesn't work that threat
just to show let's say what might be
something like sorry rook c8 maybe he
had an idea of playing Knight g4 here
and the idea of stirred a knight takes
h6 check but black has bishop t4 with
what's time and then he'll just move his
king out of the way and now or even even
consider pawn hunting but anyways
position just falls apart so after after
work f3 I'm not sure how easy it is I'm
not sure if it's it's easy to save this
position anymore this was the last last
chance Queen b3 and in something
something simple like that but no rook
rook f3 was played rook after yet
riki 397 I like this move as I said
earlier in the game I think both sides
could improve their Knights a bit the
knight on c3 Nancy three huzzahs if any
for right now because white decided play
f4 instead of f3 but blacks Knight did
its job in the opening it it got out of
the way but now now it's time for black
to to try to try to win the game and
take advantage so he'll need all his
pieces usually to do that or it's
usually a good idea to try to get all
your pieces in the net squares and I
don't see another way to do that with an
arrow be six instead moving moving that
Knight to d7 because okay you developed
a rook you could develop this rook but
there's nothing really obvious no other
open open file so that night that is a
bit easier to to reroute move like c5 c5
as possible and then maybe this is what
white was thinking in his mind it's very
easy when you're attacking to make
things work in your head it might not be
objectively sound but it's very easy to
kind of rationalize things when you're
attacking and fine variations that work
and if I'm doing that for white and
putting myself in issues maybe he was
actually going for this type of
variation maybe five let's say I swing
my Queen the c8 or something and maybe
Knight g4 here and some big nice attack
happens they should be for Knight takes
rook takes and maybe there's some sort
of attack now now it's working a bit
better than last time maybe this is this
is the attack that white envisioned I'm
not sure but at least it's a better
version than than the other variation so
I mean that's probably all I was doing a
little bit which is something I
recommend trying not to do like attack
if there's a reason to but you're you're
counting on your
to play the best defense and rather than
looking for something that works for you
it's nice to find something that works
for you but yeah make sure you're also
looking for them as best as your ability
so ninety-seven other rerouting options
would be to play 98 a bit sophisticated
and probably unnecessary and try to put
that night to you seven or 2d6 but
they're not super squares ninety seven
threatens as a threat right off the bat
threatens Knight takes e5 f takes e5 and
Bishop takes e5 because that pawn is
pinned by the rook now whites blacks
best pieces are the bishop so just get
rid of White's best piece White's best
piece is clearly the knight on e5
because of that now it wasn't there the
pawn on d4 would already be gone many
moons ago so 97 and again in this
position 97 was played and yeah Queen b3
Queen b3
yes why not clean that comes to my mind
as well I mean you got to get that Queen
out of out of that time where's the
danger where's the sense of danger here
like that's that's bad this was a black
I mean Y cannot be happy with his
awareness here he's just keeping this
Queen in the line of fire Queen b3 get
get out of the way simple as that
simple is that if yes black can take you
can open up the position but you know at
least you're not losing a pawn your
queen is not you know getting getting
attacked and yeah sure it's still a
better position for black a better
position for black to me especially
because I don't like that knight on c3
and I don't like this bishop at least I
prefer blacks pieces and long-term black
as that Queen side majority and
and an open D file right now but this is
still a game this is the game for for
most people is there's still a lot to be
a lot of opportunities for both sides
here so Queen B 3 should have been
played without a doubt and and he didn't
do that he did not do that he made
things easier and I takes d7 well I mean
what's why it's the most success
accessible pawn for black its d4 it's
not B - it's not a force on f4 it's d4
so by doing this black can also like
double on the D file gives him the rook
d7 now now this rook before I said you
know I don't see it really an easy
square now I'm just gonna double on the
D file against all those that we pawn it
just making things easier
so yeah the trades of trades are helping
black at least that type of favorable
trade with no structural like weakness
or anything like that there was a threat
it comes to tempo gives black a square
in the end just everything is great
b5
and in black paper should be seven and
you didn't need to think about that and
that's a good move
the position was already really bad here
I'm wondering if anybody can spot an
even stronger move than Bishop e7 that
just happens to kind of like highlight
why you can't be playing like this
against the two bishops and just be
opening up the lines and leaving your
queen on d1
Queen b6 is that yours so we have a
suggestion Queen b6 make some sense I I
don't
it's it's concrete it's either works or
doesn't so takes rook takes
the the queen has no square to run to no
matter what will will check so rookies
yeah but I'll play here but this is
checkmate yeah no it would almost would
all like it's not the easiest tactic for
black to go for he didn't need to what
you didn't yeah if if King h8 rook takes
h7 check and you have time to get out of
the way but King I fit on the darks on
this square and and there's nowhere to
run
it's a rookie g1 work through one is
next listen to the next yeah yeah you
play for that with compensation some of
the King yeah sure if white takes the
bishop it's double check that's the
trick that's that's why it's so nasty
yeah
otherwise it's enough material to work
in two pieces for the Queen it's it's
almost made wreckage you know it almost
is it's just it's just a deep tie like
that I wouldn't expect him to see but
it's actually available in the position
to be even more okay I'll put this a you
guys actually know that's kind of it's
something interesting Queen b6 a little
bit Messier we see if some Lions block
had to find King f8 what's the cleaner
version of this there's a cleaner
version of doing this exact thing black
to move there just poke white with those
bishops Queen b6 wins but it's a little
messy it's a bit hard to see it's not
necessary yes bishop Age 4 is a
suggestion and now where does white go
anywhere let's say let's say you tax
that's okay we'll tack it and now Queen
b6 and now now it's just a way way way
better version and at least
I see that right away I'm not I'm not
sure but to me it seems like a way way
is your version there's no way to defend
d4 so at five in my wins maybe maybe
I mean if I'm gonna be really computer
ish my mind probably this wins but
that's maybe hard to see
probably that wins with the same idea
that when work takes d4 happens it's
just lights out the Queen is done so but
but even Bishop h4 okay I mean let's say
let's say you even play this f5 move
worse comes to worse I probably just
play Bishop g5 and I'm gonna be
threatening all of these pawns and I'm
threatening to double on the D files so
you need to defend one of them as I said
you like when opening the position up I
don't I don't have any answer the back
of my my head I just know if you're
doing any of these opening moves it's
gonna favor the two bishops and yeah
I'll just I'll just like move back even
I'll just move back and it should be it
should be bad in the long term but yeah
I probably Bishop a sure but just the
position position is that rook is a
target rather than attacking piece and
it wasn't it wasn't it really hard for
black to do that ninety-seven forces the
night out then I really can't really
retreat if the retreats it can it can
retreat but you know maybe Oh actually
there's upon him so can't it really
can't really retreat yeah yeah I can't
retreat which is a means means whites
being a bit too ambitious so the game
did not last too much longer as you see
there's already no tactics coming but
black black didn't need to go for all
this this position was quite fine after
85 there should be seven he still has
the threat of Queen b6
so you didn't you know I that's nothing
that was just for fun but he did not
need to see that he still retains a
massive advantage that's I think I have
the score she caught a bit funny or I'm
not sure that this is the this is the
file I received Queen c2 but maybe it's
just wrong
yeah I'm trying to like put in my mom
what did what did he think and I think
this is maybe what happened let's just
say Queen d2 I don't have the ratings
but based on what happened the Queen
couldn't have gone to b3 cuz black Queen
b6 oh this is a bit of a puzzle here I'm
not sure guys maybe Queen d2 is played
maybe the time trouble kicked in but
black played you know what Blackwell is
so winning he does not need to take that
Queen so that's just no but seriously I
I've been happy with almost all blacks
moves white could have gone anywhere
maybe he was being sadistic I'm not sure
but it really is winning it really is
winning so he really yeah we can make a
move for white here and move the Queen
out of the way and it's still completely
you know lost for the most part like
okay we'll play Queen see when we'll
lose a pawn but once a for respond Hank
so we have to ignore that for a little
bit he gets his Queen other way so now
we're back to the normal position but
the d4 pawn was hanging on no matter
what white did that rook on g3 cannot
swing back to d3 because of the bishop
one thing I do remember looking at was
there was yeah we saw that
okay the claps here is very quick Rick
d4 moves his king over rook takes Queen
D for this yeah
or why not queen f2 Queen have to clean
have to sorry we have to would have
wrapped things up faster
I guess just should have three I mean
that rook on g3 is really ridiculous
mm-hmm yeah it moves like that it's not
I mean it's it's over I guess it's just
a matter of choice like there's bishop
at five here but it's there's no force
checkmate so maybe white maybe black
just one upon he plays Queen D fourth
the idea of Queen d2 and because what
White's work is offside on here then all
the other pawns were hanging in the
background kazoos but it is totally
winning f5 is now played Bishop f5 so I
mean it looks like position just went
downhill super fast but it was already
in your loss there was one chance for
white
I'll just quickly go through the moves
here Bishop h5 Queen d2 yeah so that's
what you want to do that rook on G is
really really really misplaced b3 two
pawns now two pawns two pawns is winning
but more most importantly here like all
the pieces that knight on c3 which I've
been saying as a bad piece the entire
game is still there so there's a few
more moves and this is the end of the
score sheet actually it is a forced loss
as far as I know all you do is you move
the rook let's say to c1 and follow up
next move with Bishop to c5 and black I
mean why can't stop that but there was
one last thing I would like to say is in
this position there should be seven
there was one last try for white to keep
the game a little bit competitive if
anybody has a suggestion here it's it's
just to gain some space he doesn't have
his rook on g3 can't get to d3 his
Knight and Bishop are bad the knight on
c3 Bishop I need to her bad
and bishops work well in Paris that's
it's kind of the hint there yep
there should be three that's what I like
that's what came in my mind I don't know
what the computer says but Bishop d3
get rid of that bishop then if we want
to you know well first of all guys just
just to double check you can't you know
there's a tactic there but but it frees
yeah I mean let's say position like this
Queen rook takes is possible and not
really at least yeah
Queen takes not as good Rick takes and
it's still there's so some chances to
hold we traded some pieces and now maybe
we can play 92 or something and and
really over to Fendi for it still better
be for black because the pawns are on
the color of blacks Bishop years ago
inside majority but there's still
fighting chance so here he had a chance
tactically I mean first to play Bishop
d3 get rid of the two bishops and yeah
he might lose a pawn but at least he did
trade off a worse piece for a good piece
because we saw how effective this Bishop
was it stops the knight from going here
it stops it was supposed to stop with
the Queen from gonna see to it didn't do
that but it did most of it did most of
this job and and now and yeah after
after after this just every single piece
of blacks was better than whites and
that's that's why he lost but it really
came down to to that that decision to
give up the darker bishops and and
continue to attack without reason so I
think it was very well came very very
well played game by black but white
can't be too happy happy with his play
other than the first few opening moves
just cannot attack recklessly like that
and make reckless